wow yeah yeah
um so that that's one thing I think that
you explained pretty well is I think a
lot of people
they don't understand all of the options
that they have
to acquire rental properties to acquire
properties to invest in I think uh we're
in a really weird space right now
because the rates went up yeah and I
don't feel like the property value has
adjusted to the rate hike yet no
um would you suggest people buying right
now because it feels like it's kind of
like at least just I'm not an expert
like you but it for my from my
perspective it feels like it's probably
the wrong time to buy
so right now the Market's a little funny
right
it is
anybody buying a single family home I
will kind of hold off on that because
that's where you're going to see your
biggest correction yeah right as far as
rental properties multi-families it's on
fire
like it's not gonna stop because rents
are up so high right right so you know
I'll give you an example like uh three
family Paterson New Jersey you probably
get it right now for 500 000 right but
just you know just simple numbers right
let's name account taxes say uh you get
a seven percent right
oh maybe you buy the rate down and get a
six percent let's say it's three
thousand what's the rate right now
as of yesterday uh it was like 6.9 for
30-year fix uh
for a 15 year it was like 6.5 damn it's
crazy how much it jumped and then the
adjustable was a little bit lower right
yeah so let's say right now you go to
Patterson and let's say you get lucky
you buy the rate down you get a property
for 500 000. you buy that property uh
let's say your mortgage just round
numbers right now getting to all of it
right let's say it's three thousand
dollars a month right
so right lower right
in that market right in your apartment
because it was a three family you could
get about 4 500 a month right
so
you actually make more money now the
rate is actually higher
threats are so high so now instead of
getting fifteen hundred dollars for that
apartment I'm getting 2 500.
um so I'm not making 7 500 compared to
making the 45 right yeah my mortgage is
let's say three thousand plus taxes
Insurance whatever that is it I'm at
five thousand let's say Olin I'm still
making 2500 a month yeah so that's the
difference yeah and like and and you're
in a place where you know you have
tenants so it's like
if it ever corrects you can refinance
right
if the rate goes down you know
it's right right no more rates have
always been between five to six yeah
what's what happened recently was kind
of like fake because they were trying to
save the housing market from covid right
yeah so it's like we got kind of spoiled
for sure my first property that I bought
it was with the state alone back in 04
and my interest rate was eight percent
wow the only difference was that back
then right compared to now
the uh the rates were high but the rents
didn't support the mortgage payment yeah
now the rents even if you want a single
family support whatever the payment is
monthly because the rents are so high
yep so you can still cash flow in any
market and the rental class
so let's say somebody has let's say
they've saved up 50 bands right they got
50k and they want to they're making
decent money let's say they're making I
don't know 150 000 a year 100 say
they're in the six figures with the low
six figures range and they want to get
into getting their first rental property
um I know there's like tons of options
for people to
um whether it's a hard money loan
obviously there's a conventional loan
you mentioned the FHA loan earlier if
you're that person what route are you
taking to try to uh to to get get that
first property right in today's climate
right now if you have no experience
right I wouldn't do a flip and I
wouldn't do a property to rehab I would
definitely get a rental as cash flowing
right uh that that's what I would do
right it all depends what program you
want to use right right you could do FHA
right and you put uh three and a half
percent down you could uh do a
conventional product I think uh
conventional right now on a two family
investment you get away with putting ten
percent down
uh you could go state it right the
stated program that kind of caused the
bubble last time is back what is the
stated thing so stay the program now
it's called well it's it's really it's
not called stated anymore it's the asset
based load right so meaning you don't
have to show any tax returns you put uh
15 to 20 percent
rental income to the property is making
so they're they'll pretty much completed
Simone is one in which they know that
you're
renting the property out because they
have to be able to see the numbers make
sense yeah so the numbers that the
numbers have to make sense all you need
is good credit right you need probably
at least uh 680 credit score you need uh
to show the the money in the bank it
doesn't have to be seasoned or the money
you could just transfer right over it's
not like a FHA product but they're not
going to be like it'll show us two years
of your bank statements yes yes it's not
like that
um you need an appraisal title the
leases for the property that's it you
get a loan in 45 to 60 days wow which
that program is very popular right now
because a lot of people don't don't
aren't qualifying for conventional
Finance right so that that program
everybody's using it right now wow and
then for like a hard money loan or a
line of credit situation would you say
that those are more the options you
would go to if you need to make a like a
flip on a property yeah because it's
more of a short-term thing right
definitely you know as far as flipping
properties hard money is the way to go
yeah right uh Farm money right now what
experience you're looking at uh 90 90 on
to Value 100 on the rehab meaning you
only got to put 10 down and you're gonna
give you all the rehab dollars for
people who don't know what a hard money
loan is just kind of break it down so
Harmony loan is pretty much private
financing yeah it's a way of moving
quicker because when it comes to
rehabbing properties uh there is not a
lot of options it's either a Harmony
loan or a FHA 203k loan FHA to free k
loan you have to live in the property
okay our money is pretty much for
investors yeah right it goes under an
LLC it doesn't appear on your personal
credit report right but you have to it
costs money right yeah the interest
rate's a lot higher it's a lot higher it
could be anywhere between eight to
twelve percent but you move fast right
and real estate when you find a good
deal that's the whole thing you need
speed you need to have that cash rate
that's it so hard money is considered
the same thing as cash so when you go on
the auction side and it tells you cash
only technically that means that you can
also use hard money
um it means the same thing where do you
like because I know that like there's
different types of hard money lenders
but like for people who have no idea how
to find a hard money lender or how to
even get
involved in that world like where did
where is a good place to start with that
well when I first started it was a
little bit harder right because I got
back in a way when everything crashed
but now there's hard money lenders
everywhere yeah yeah there's hard money
Leathers everywhere you know you could
type in a Harmony lender and uh just on
Google on Instagram anywhere and it pops
up and then those what they do is
essentially they have a like they do
their insurance is the property right
yeah so pretty much a Harmony lender
will not do a deal unless there's me on
the bone it has to make sense right so
for example if you're trying to flip a
property right and it needs to rehab and
it's worth three hundred thousand
dollars right and you're paying 300 000
they're not gonna do that deal because
God forbid if you don't pay and they
take the property away there's no meat
on the boat yeah there's no problem
they're gonna break even what's the
point of them risking it now if that
property if it's worth 300 000 but you
get it for 220. you're all in yeah what
rehab
yeah so pretty much a government rule
that kind of gives you an idea
30 money to make for for him
right where
at the end of the day
they don't want you to pay because they
want your deal right so yeah you pay the
higher interest rate whatever but at the
end of the day it's all about risk so
they want to make sure this deal is
worth it
yo there is like an art I got a homie uh
DJ Christian in the Tampa area who uh
he's been flipping houses for 10 years
now and
he always would tell me there's like
little things when you flip a house like
you could go go down to the color of the
door like what are some of the like
random little like things that people
don't think about let's say if they're
rehabbing a house to flip or if they're
just rehabbing a house to add some value
to their own property
like what are some of those like hacks
that that you always make sure your
houses have
well when it comes to different
properties right and rental properties
yeah
I only go into the properties when I do
my walkthrough to make sure the uh you
know it's worth it before my contractors
go in there right and kind of tell them
but we already have a system in place
where
I don't have to be there or even talk to
my guys anymore they pretty much know
everything that you have to do because
the problem is with these properties
right at the end of the day you want to
make money yeah my first property that I
purchased to flip this was a flip
property I went in there I wanted
everything designer to paint this I went
crazy with it I want to do this I want
to do that the nicest thing everything
nice yeah it was a it was a three family
that was flipping at the time
and two of the units I had tenants in
them so me and my wife are arguing about
fixtures right that right nightmare
and then I go back to the property I
ended up having to evict somebody right
in that unit and in six months
right and I'm like yo all this headache
picking all these nights
now with me it's just a system right I
buy everything in bulk for my Apartments
the same floors everything yeah it's
just automatic I don't even have to
think about it my guys don't gotta think
about it that's so once you identify
that system it makes everything so much
easier yep because you're because it's
like you're scaling just yo we know what
our yeah
yeah because I mean right now there's
obviously a shortage on a lot of
supplies and stuff has that made things
like a little more difficult for you or
is it just you just got to pay more yeah
more you know for me on the rental side
of the business it doesn't affect me
right because yeah I'm paying more for
material but I'm making more on the
right on the rent yeah right and before
even you know wood all the other stuff
you know uh wire whatever it was
it didn't really matter because the
values went up so high after covet right
so you were still making that money up
anyway right right right that was a
little different but again the market
right now the values have not got down
yet right it's probably not going to
happen for another you're probably
looking at like about a year yeah about
another year right before you really see
a big change right especially in the
tri-state area where we are like values
are just like yeah like we're still
getting five ten offers on the property
crazy yeah so it hasn't changed yet
maybe eventually it will but again you
don't know what could happen a year from
now